[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
things have changed so fast so
dramatically this year
that it's hard to remember what a very
different country this was on new year's
morning
back then a little over seven months ago
the us felt politically volatile it
definitely was there was an election
coming
but it still felt fundamentally american
there was no mistaking this country for
any other country
we weren't mexico or luxembourg or
burundi
we definitely weren't china yes most of
our consumer goods did seem to be
manufactured
in asia but our way of life our system
our society
seemed to be the very opposite of
china's
the chinese were enslaved we were free
that was the difference and it was
permanent it would never change
not one in a thousand americans doubted
that
in january for example dr anthony fauci
at the time not yet a household name
did an interview with the journal of the
american medical association to talk
about america's response to the wuhan
coronavirus
fauci explained the authoritarian
measures the chinese government had
taken to contain that virus
then fauci noted almost offhandedly that
in america
none of that would be allowed watch
they've not only shut out the traffic
out of wuhan planes
trucks buses ferries
rail but they've done it to a number of
the surrounding cities
so rather than say historically it
doesn't do much good which is
true i think it's important to wait and
see
that maybe the chinese because of the
state
of their society that they're able to do
that
i mean as you well know there's no
chance in the world
that we could do that to chicago or to
new york or to san francisco
as you well know there is no chance in
the world that we could do that to
chicago or to new york or to san
francisco that's what fauci said
note his use of the word to the chinese
government was doing these things
to its people not for them in other
words these were punishments not
remedies
and none of that would ever be allowed
here in a free country just couldn't
happen in america
fauci's words seem quaint now like a fax
machine or a black and white photograph
fauci himself has since become one of
the most strident advocates of a chinese
response to coronavirus
but he's hardly alone in that yesterday
the mayor of new york announced that he
plans to erect armed checkpoints around
the perimeter of the city
and use plain closed government agents
to follow citizens to their homes
it would have been impossible to imagine
any of that in january
yet de blasio's announcement didn't seem
especially shocking
we're used to it now that's how similar
to china we have become
it's a big change but like all seismic
shifts it happened incrementally before
it
happened overnight for years we watched
our leaders prostrate themselves before
the chinese government
most of us just assumed they were greedy
that's why they were doing it china was
paying their bills so they bowed
we never imagined they actually admired
the chinese system
oh but they did and that became clear
with the arrival of the chronovirus
the first tip was their resolute refusal
to admit where the virus came from
when strong evidence emerged from
chinese scientists
that the disease originated in a lab in
wuhan
our leaders immediately and adamantly
diminished
dismissed it as a conspiracy theory they
didn't want to know more
their first instinct was to defend china
they didn't want the chinese system
discredited that seemed confusing but we
soon learned
why the democratic political act was
zeke emanuel was among the first to
reveal
how the left planned to use the pandemic
to change the united states
here he is on msnbc four months ago this
week
realistically kova 19 will be here for
the next
18 months or more we will not be able to
return to normalcy
until we find a vaccine or effective
medications
is all that economic pain worth trying
to stop covet 19.
the truth is we have no choice
oh the truth is we have no choice
except in a democracy we always
have a choice that's why it's different
from an autocracy in a democracy
on the big questions the public gets to
decide
what the public wants the people rule
that's the whole point of the american
system
but the left had no plans to let the
public decide
anything so instead they issued resolute
decrees
remain at home wear a mask do not
congregate with
others no one asked voters what they
thought about any of this democracy
played
no role in it the orders came down men
with guns
enforced the orders the government used
sophisticated technology to track down
anyone who disobeyed them
just like in china here's los angeles
mayor eric garcetti
this has really been marvelously
embraced by 99.9 percent of people we
see it in the traffic data
we see it in the cell phone data but
we're going to hunt down that last point
one percent and say
you got to get inside you got to cut it
out and you got a distance
oh most people obey but we're going to
hunt down the last one in other words
no dissent of any kind allowed
just like in china in china the
government loads disobedient citizens
into trucks
and carts them away we have video of
that happening in los
angeles they just starve you out they
take away your water and your
electricity
these large parties are unsafe and can
cost
angelinos their lives that is why
tonight i am authorizing the city
to shut off los angeles department of
water and power service
in the egregious cases in which houses
businesses and other venues
are hosting unpermitted large gatherings
recognize that in some ways all
authoritarian societies are the same
they are characterized by corruption
a lack of social trust any deep cynicism
about government all those attitudes are
endemic in china
suddenly they are nearly universal in
this country
the public understands that our leaders
are lying to us
politicians use lockdowns for political
ends in the name of public health they
reward supporters and they punish their
opponents they're barely hiding this
anymore they've done it since day one
but most of us
wrongly assumed that our bill of rights
would prevent them from going too far
that was our backstop against tyranny
but we were wrong
the bill of rights has not prevented
them from doing precisely
what they want to do in state after
state governors for example have
targeted the faithful
on the assumption that most traditional
christians do not vote democrat
therefore they must be punished now
banning the exercise of religion is
unconstitutional
obviously it's a direct violation of the
letter and the spirit of the first
amendment it's never happened
before but they have made it happen
they've done it
anyway as in china our government has
enthusiastically persecuted christians
here's new jersey governor phil murphy
explaining
you have closed church services and
synagogue services and arrested people
for attempting to attend them
did anyone say that maybe practicing
your faith might be important to
someone's mental health listen i think
we've had a very good
uh good common ground with faith leaders
of
literally every faith who understand
this
so listen carefully governor murphy says
he has reached agreement with those
faith leaders who quote understand this
he doesn't say anything about the faith
leaders who quote don't
understand this the leaders should
instead like to worship their god as the
constitution guarantees
they can there's no common ground for
them
they will be arrested just as they are
in china nor can they fight back
in a free society self-defense is the
most basic right
all other rights rest upon it
self-defense is illegal
in china and suddenly it's illegal in
this country too
the democratic party's militia loot
stores deface our cities attack people
with impunity they are rarely punished
for doing it
yet americans who try to protect their
families from the violence
face the full rage of the state they
risk going to jail they have been
indicted
as in china there are now two standards
of justice the party has decided
who can be armed everyone else must
submit
it wasn't always this way in the united
states in fact
until recently we had a functioning
constitution
but anyone who remembers that is a
threat to the state history itself
is a threat to the state in china there
is no history
like religion the past is purely a
political tool to be shaped by temporal
leaders seeking to protect their power
in place of god the state offers secular
cults in which citizens worship
party approved political martyrs doesn't
sound very american
but suddenly it is we are here
to honor george floyd for those who
wish to we will now kneel for our moment
of silence
anyone who challenges the cult who
refuses to join it
who won't kneel before it is punished
and then their complaints are scrubbed
from the permanent record china does
this
chinese censors scour the internet to
make certain dangerous ideas never reach
the public
does that sound familiar to you that's
where our tech oligarchs
learned it the united states in other
words very clearly is becoming very much
like china at very high speed
that doesn't mean the two countries are
identical there's still real differences
between them
in china for example leaders still think
beyond the next election
they don't have real elections so they
can take a long-term view
and in china they understand that
countries in which the population is
divided
against itself countries in which
citizens have nothing
meaningful in common with one another
are weak
countries and over time countries like
that are doomed
and so china emphatically rejects
identity politics it's illegal there
leaders in china don't narrow cast to
tiny constituencies based on their quote
identity
the idea is appalling to them the
chinese focus instead
on national identity they don't worship
diversity
they promote unity and that's why long
term
they believe they will win the chinese
also believe and this is another
striking difference
that their economy is worth saving they
didn't destroy it with chronovirus
quarantines
harsh as they were unlike the united
states china was a
poor place until fairly recently and so
they know firsthand that poor countries
are
powerless and they don't want that in
other words
the chinese care about themselves and
their future
and that's one thing we could actually
learn from them but we don't seem to be